the sound of the explosion ripped
through havana's old town it blew off a
big part of the front of the saratoga
hotel one of the most luxurious and
expensive in the cuban capitals
preliminary investigations indicate it
was caused by a gas leak says the cuban
president's office
movie stars and celebrities like madonna
had stayed in the saratoga now rescue
workers and locals are searching for
people missing under the rubble
it was a blast that threw me out there
apparently it could have been worse no
tourists were staying at the hotel
because it was undergoing renovations
said the havana governor
president miguel diaz-canel arrived at
the scene shortly after the blast
there's a group of people receiving help
there are rescue teams the specialized
emergency forces
we have deaths unfortunately the
hospitals are dealing with the injured
the explosion damaged other buildings
around the hotel too there were worries
especially about a nearby primary school
authorities say that thankfully the
children and teachers there are okay
buildings in havana's beautiful but
disintegrating old town often suffer
falling masonry but explosions are rare
this one has shocked the island
john holman al jazeera